[موسيقى]
طبيبه تعيش وسط القمامه فيديو اثار الغضب
والتعاطف في ان الواحد بين رواد السوشيال
ميديا في مصر ما القصه
[موسيقى]
نسرين سيده في العقد الخامس من عمرها وجدت
نفسها بعد سنوات تعيش واقعا قاسيا مختلفا
تماما عن حياتها السابقه التي لا تتذكر
منها الكثير فصدمات حياتها تركتها في حاله
نفسيه تجعل من ماضيها لغزا لمن يريدون
مساعدتها
[موسيقى]
انطلقت سمر نديم مؤسسه دار زهره مصر
استغاثه من اشخاص فطرت قلوبهم بمشهد نسرين
وطلبوا منها مساعدتها حيث كانت تعيش في
الشارع بمنطقه تبه وتحديدا في ملف
للسيارات اعرضها مره اصطدام احدى السيارات
بها ما تسبب لها في كسور واصبحت تنام على
بطنها طوال الوقت بسبب الالم ورغم سلوكها
العنيف ورفضها التحرك استطاعت سمر مع فريق
طبي متخصص نقل السيده الى الدار وتوفير
الرعايه اللازمه لها
[موسيقى]
و خلال محاولتي كشف لغز نسرين روت انها
كانت طبيبه وانها لم يسبق لها الزواج
ووالدها متوفيان ولكنها تم اختطافها في
عام 2017 ثم انتهى بها الامر في الشارع
ولا تتفاعل مع اي محاوله كشف تفاصيل اكثر
ولم يتم العثور على اي اوراق يستدل منها
على هويتها لكنها مثقفه وتستطيع الحديث
بالانجليزيه والفرنسيه ولازال البحث عن
اهلها مستمرا
اول مره جئنا عشان ناخدها
بصورها وفيديوهات على صفحات التواصل
الاجتماعي على صفحتي ظهرت مصر
نزلت لها من حوالي شهرين او شهر ونصف
حاولت ان انا اخذها معرفتش اخذها ابدا ما
رضتش تقوم معايا
حالتها ساقت اكثر طبعا قاعده الشارع مش
حلوه مش اا يعني مش حلوه لاي بني ادم مش
حلوه لاي حد ولا الانسان ولا الحيوان
للاسف هي كانت قاعده في مكان يعني ملف ملف
لعرضه لاي حاجه
حصل لها حادثه بقت نايمه على بطنها
فالموضوع اكتر وبقيت تعبانه اكثر لماذا كل
هذه المده ولم يساعدها احد لماذا بعد كل
هذه المده علمتي عنها هو كانت بقالها احنا
سالنا طبعا الناس اللي كانوا حواليها في
المكان السكان وبتوع ال- الخضار والمحلات
وكل الاماكن سالناهم قالوا ان هي كانت
جايه ولابسه شيك جدا وكان بقى لها ست شهور
في المكان ده لانه مفيد ليه قاعده مكانها
ما تحركتش وكانت ناس كثير بتحاول معها
تقومها بس كان كل احد يجيء يطلب منها كانت
تشتمه تضربه وتتف عليه وكان بتعمل حاجات
صعبه جدا جدا اي بني ادم يعني يتحملها
ظروفها المرضيه وعارفه ان ليس على المريض
حرج ليس على المريض حرج وهي تعبانه
فيديوهات كتير
مع من يحاول يساعدها كيف قدرتوا تساعدوها
انتم وتنقلوها لدار الرعايه بصي هي كانت
نايمه على بطنها انا جالي فيديو لها وهي
بين الحياه والموت وكانت وضعها الصحي صعب
جدا خلاص انا قررت اليوم ده ان انا مش
هسيبها ابدا وكان عندي اصرار جوايا غريب
لما شفتها بالحاله دي جاء لي الفيديو ده
الساعه 10:00 على صفحات توصل الاجتماعي
اتصلت بالدكتور الامراض النفسيه قلت له
ابعث لي فريق طبي بعد اذنك همم حتى لو باي
باي نوع من انواع حتى لو بفلوس انا عايزه
فريق طبي بيجيء لي محترم ينقذ الست الطيبه
دي من عذاب الشارع لان ما حدش هيشلها طيب
الدكتوره عشان اعمل محضر اثبات حاله
بالفعل و- و- ورحت لها ثاني على ال- همم
على المكان اللي هي قاعده فيه واخذتها
بقرار من القسم ان انا اخذها في فطار ظهرت
مصر للكبار مقوى والفريق الطبي بالفعل
والدها حقنه مهدئه وشيلناها في العربيه
وطلعنا بيها هنا على الدار هي نسرين
مفاجاه المفاجاه انها دكتوره طب وين اهلها
وين العياده اللي كانت تشتغل فيها وين
مستشفى وين الناس عنها من كلها السنين
اللي قاعده فيهم بهذا الوضع المزري للاسف
للاسف للاسف انا ما قدرتش اسوق اوصل لحد
الان لحد من اهلها ونفسي بعد الفيديو ده
وبعد همم كل ده نقدر نوصل لحد من اهلها هي
كانت مين وايه وضعاها كانت عايشه ازاي ما
شاء الله عليها راقيه جدا جدا جدا عارفه
حاجات كثير يعني لما بتقعد مع الناس
بتتكلم معهم يعني في ناس بتجيء تشوفها هنا
في الدار بتتكلم معهم عن شخصياتهم
والابراج وعن تاريخ ميلادهم ما شاء الله
يعني حاجه كويسه
[موسيقى]